[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
oh
elle gît la prochaine ck magloire qui
vient ce soir ma gloire avec son petit
chien
moi je m'en veux énormément parce que
c'est quand il est venu ici et que son
chien oui je dis j'en prends 1 et voilà
maintenant à ce chien s'est ouvert
d'esprit ça amuse et votre fils ne l'a
pas dit beaucoup mon fils moi ça m'amuse
- mais s'amuse beaucoup mon fils
pourquoi il faut le sortir il faut
ramasser les crottes et les oui c'est
pas ça c'est que sa mort tous morts tout
à nos jours il s'est attaqué au plancher
il a détruit un morceau du plancher
[Musique]
ou alors vous prenez un coach pour
éduquer votre chien
ça se fait
j'espère que pas bien avec son chien
[Musique]
superbus à dijon
oui bonsoir bonsoir daniel picouly au
quatrième étage me faire s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
oui monsieur
magloire vient avec son chien oui tu
peux le garder toi le chien je garde et
je fais le service elle maintient dans
les bras ouais je vais le promener je
viens c'est plus de services
[Musique]
soit mais chez bonsoir
je lui permettent de concevoir votre
manteau
merci bonsoir bonsoir et moins coûteuse
énième ça va bien très bien ouais
tu vois quoi pas comme toi un peu de
champagne pour l'ami du bien 10 la vie
en art 10 ans c'est ce qu'on dit c'est
ce qu'en disent ceux qui se garent son
service au nez le livre avec les maoris
ville il est il déjà j'aime crinqué moi
un beau jeudi pour ce qu'elle est un
beau jeudi pour tekken est dit qu il
déjà dans les classements et au hockey
fait passer jamais si c'est
incroyable non mais c'est d'aider des
sceaux qui sont assez rares c'est rare
et avec tout ce qui a été fait aux
doigts autour du bouquin les gens
viennent tereos à l'envi je fais les
signatures et j'ai des nouveautés 26 12
ans méfie des gens qui te lis pour la
première fois
du tout il vient il commence et il
commence par un bon je dis ça c'est dit
et ça c'est un bonheur incroyable et
c'est alors pourquoi quelqu'un a décidé
un jour peut commencer avec toi il doit
commencer par un tueur ni de n'importe
quel âge mais ce qu'ils vont racheter
les anciens
souvent ce que je vois c'est le cas
souvent c'est le cas d'ailleurs je
prends mon tgv là vous entrez dans leur
mental yves ouais même auteur ouais là
c'est déjà ça laissez la refroidir un
peu et j'ai eu un petit point z et puis
j'essaie de leur expliquer des
itinéraires parce que maintenant tu vois
un mec qui te demande de signer un beau
jeudi pour tuer kennedy tu lui vendre
ceux d'avant ah oui ils ont rythmé
bouquin c'était terrible ton premier
polar c'était la lumière des fous super
sombre comme histoire ventre est resté
coi l'histoire histoire c'était
l'histoire véridique qui se passe un an
presque après un beau jeudi pour tuer
kennedy quand j'étais au lycée une de
mes copines de classe est allé apporter
dans les toilettes ouais et les revenus
après c'était un prof qui était voilà
que c'est un prof qui était le père de
ça et après l ua c'est vrai un petit
cadeau après il a fait un petit cadeau
et moi ce qui m'a sidéré en tant que mec
tout
tout comme mon tu peux aller avorter
dans les toilettes et revenir en classe
on voit rien un jour j'étais revenue
tout de suite il est revenu après en
classe rhum avant la même dans la même
classe moyenne même classe et nous on
n'a rien vu crabe et et moi un jour
puisque j'étais prof je sais quand même
pas possible et un jour j'avais devant
moi une fille s'appelle grâce y est je
me rappelle très bien si vous voulez
grassi est au chaud même si vous n'êtes
pas au courant elle a eu son enfant
cette fille était mon élève de seconde
elle était enceinte devant moi et j'ai
rien vu ouais j'ai rien vu s habiller un
peu entre comme ça l'affairé est revenue
tranquillement comme ça moi le le
courage moi dans mes livres le courage
des femmes mais devenant ainsi des sites
est ton premier bouquin ouest après les
pôles arabe nous avons des polars celui
là c'est vrai j'ai la lettre
c'est la série noire l'a trouvé trop
noir pour la noire non mais c'est
l'expression qui sont utilisés qu'une
sage de garder ça je vois là mais moi
j'aime bien ce que tu racontes de rambo
jeudi pour tuer quelques mois je suis
assez je me rends compte c'est normal
c'est l'âge mais j'ai assez nostalgique
de sept de ses années 60 la du début des
années 60 tu sais que j'ai à un moment
j'ai acheté des vieilles voitures puis
bon c'était c'était infernal c'était
trop cher c'était tu prends et quoi toi
vu des vrais des vraies voitures
maintenant j'achète des modèles réduits
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus simple je
joue avec mes modèles réduits et je me
rends compte je suis fasciné par toutes
les automobiles populaire des années 60
je veux aller là j'ai tout j'ai acheté
toute la collection des tractions des
dds 19 toute la collection des peugeot
ticks à 129 font des fortunes avec sa
suivante ça dans les kiosques moi je
crois qu'il ya les baby boomers enfin la
pipe ou meurs maintenant on va à une
mouche achète un truc à tous les numéros
tous les numéros j'achète et j'ai la
traction rouge de l'action des pompiers
voilà l'attraction des pompes il est
d'ailleurs dans un beau jeudi pour tuer
kennedy ouais il ya une voiture de
pompiers une traction de pont prix sont
en noir et ben ça vient de là moi j'ai
une traction gcl j'ai pas de permis mais
j'ai une traction maintenant plusieurs
années à la campagne avait permis de nom
mais un jour j'étais c'était donc 19e je
me promène je vois la traction c'est la
même que celle de mon père wen
4609 ses 75 je me rappelle encore la
même je vais voir le gars tu dis je la
chacune 4 a dévoilé le prix sinon je
l'achète je l'achète il a une et c'est
comme ça on va faire un petit réellement
il s'arrête et dit maintenant que j'ai
pas le permis ouais ouais mais qu'il
était sidéré que vous achetez pas
regarder haye pour la regarder comme
pour bernard mendy j'ai plein de
voitures que j'ai acheté pour les
regarder qu'à un moment je me suis dit
que c'était con parce que vu le nombre
de voitures que je voulais avoir ça
allait me ruiner et ça allait prendre
toute la place donc maintenant je
l'achète aux antilles comme ça et quand
je rentre chez moi c'est horrible quand
suffit tout seul chez moi je les regarde
mais oui non mais moi j'ai relancé après
tatoue d ariane way to tatou la série
es-a et chambre
des petits
modèles oui mais ça c'était parce que
c'est c'est eh voiture qui faisait rêver
chaque année les voitures changé en
rajoutait une baguette de chrome os que
j'aime bien sachez que
ces vieilleries oui parce qu'en plus ce
moment pas été était carrossier ouais
c'est bien qu'il ait racheté
complètement des guerriers ailés il a
fait une simca 5 à ma mère d'un élève un
superbe et ma mère a voulu essayer
d'apprendre à conduire dans une juva 4 g
24 est la première voiture de vente rcng
la 4g va 4 milliards et les porte qui
s'ouvrait dans le mauvais sens voilà et
bien elle a embouti un et mon père a
revendu le site 15,5 pour pas tué ma
mère mais tu y es tu là dsk pas bien non
ça mais la ds19 c'est une voiture qui
n'a pas brillé toujours toujours
d'actualité avec chez c est la déesse et
le renne le plus douloureux pour moi mes
parents moisson en histoire buteau je
sais que si j'avais gagné de l'argent à
prendre ne rien faire une ds ds 23
électronique un ancien c'est ça qu'il
voulait dire et se gagnent 3 electronic
ag m'en souviens parfaitement
l'intérieur je la vois très bien elle
opérait un jeu toujours mon rêve j'ai
jeanne chalard au menton je lui posais
devant jallet le magic part avoir deux
ça c'est ça je vois ça me file des
frissons il n'a jamais pu s'acheter sa
le pour ida le voit il avait acheté
j'avais eu à 4 à présent acheter une
dauphine ouais mais bon ils sont jamais
été jusque là dr sein est la dauphine
fallait fallait les mettre mes terres
soit du béton soit un sac de farine 2
avant parce que sinon ça partait mon
père lui a aimé un une deux en plomb
devant parce que sinon la voiture elle
faisait ça ah oui complètement moi j'ai
quitté mon travail j'en ai plein ddg
j'achète toutes les collections mais là
alors le problème si tu veux c'est qu'au
lieu de les acheter en une seule fois où
ça vachement agréable d achetée au
kiosque
parce que tu attends tu vois je dis tout
le temps mais alors vous la recevez
quand la prochaine peugeot y attendais
mais je sais tous les quinze jours avait
eu la semaine dernière soyez gentil
monsieur tu veux comme j'attends pendant
quelques jours pour avoir une du une
jupe à catherine ouais mais moi moi ça
ça me ça me plaît et je voulais faire un
voulu faire un documentaire sur les
séries faisant ça qu'on veut qu'on vend
en kiosque j'adorerais voir l'usi où on
les en boutique
je trouve que c'est la très jolie sujets
ont fait pas un documentaire sur les
voitures populaires des années sept
mois je disais j'ai pris j'ai appris à
écrire en bricolant mon père c'est à
dire que quand il bricolait sur le
moteur d'abord au début j'ai tenu à
l'amp j'étais l'arpette génial j'adore
ce mot faire l'arpette tu éclairer les
mains et quand il parle du déclin visage
comprend une dilemmien après il dépasse
moi la clé de 14 puis un jour il tend la
main il dit rien je trouve la bonne clé
et ainsi de suite bien un jour tu as le
droit ne pond celel toit et un jour tu
as droit de posséder et de mettre la
lumière rasante et l'ail te dis ouais tu
vois non non c'est pas fini et tu
recommences et maintenant j'ai
l'impression quand je bosse quand tu
écris tu es libre ouais c'est la
marqueterie cdh assez largement et j'ai
appris et appris le métier d'écrire mon
bricolant
mon père était mon père était
martiniquais martiniquais il était il a
souffert en france 2 benoît bachelet et
je m'en suis aperçu qu'avec le temps
c'était quand même un gars qui d'abord
il voulait plus blanc que blanc dans
l'écriture dans la façon de parler il
avait une écriture formidable mon père
est maintenant c'est douloureux quand
j'ai vu qu'il se mettait la tête sous
l'eau il avait des cheveux crépus il a
glissé je voyais tirer comme ça tire et
coinstar bon je comprenais pas pourquoi
parce que bon quand il avait mon père
vers 40 45 ans toutacoo revient de
l'école il avait dessiné la martinique
sur les murs il n'a jamais parlé on n'a
jamais vu un type on joue on n'a jamais
parlé de rome pas d'acquérir du tout et
tout à coup il ya eu un coup de blues
aïe je me suis demandé ce que c'était et
il nous a dessiné la plage du carbet et
lamar thiais et la caravelle de
christophe colomb 1 et on était là en
train de manger la soupe d'entre eux une
moto à chaîne et 30-0 voyez les caramels
c'est celle qui va découvrir l'amérique
à la plage du card mais parce que l'été
vous aviez pas tellement en vacances en
martinique c'est à dire plus pour
l'algérie oui mais sur absolument mon
père il travaillait
à toulouse ou en algérie pour gagner des
sous il faisait des déplacements et un
jour et nous a il nous a emmenés là-bas
et ouais j'ai christ et la force de
l'eau 15 km d'alger où pour la première
fois j'avais la gueule des mômes du coin
j'arrive et la première scène de fort de
l'eau que je raconte c'est le boom il
arrive et on est là on a vu en train de
bouffer tranquillement je regarde la mer
j'aurais jamais lu ça la baie d'alger
c'est toi tu es là tu viens de tacite et
tout à prouver comme ça et moi je mange
mon petit sandwich et puis il ya un
larbi qui m'a trapu il me met une raclée
sur le terrain bol c'est parti dans tous
les sens en criant khallouf khallouf
c'est une chance j'avais des jambes en
voilà il fait ça j'étais un petit
musulman c'était un petit âne et au lieu
d meurtri de ça j'étais content je suis
d'ici c'est la première fois tu sais ton
grand père qui avait posé une tarnaise
une tarbaise heim est donc tajan à
tarbes atelier foot et la tare mais
parce qu'il est venu pour la guerre et
puis les nos arsenaux travail aux
arsenaux parce qu'il était chaudronnier
et la trouver du boulot là-bas et la
guerre de 14 18 il a trouvé du boulot de
chaudronnier parce qu'il était
chaudronnier qualifier ah ouais c'est
donc ton père était déjà le fils will et
déjà le fils dindane c'est pour ça qu'il
essayait de s'en va francisée et puis
aussi d'oublier le fait que tu mama ma
grand-mère a sombré dans l'alcool a
vraiment hâte garbez avoir complètement
parce que quand quand on imagine sa
situation elle était complètement
rejetés de sa famille lui a été elle a
été femme d'un noir en 1920 et plus à
elle a eu un enfant handicapé toile on
est des choses dures un local a sombré
dans l'alcool et jeu et quand je lisais
sellette et comme mon père mon père n'a
jamais pu parler de sa mère tellement
ses douleurs l'arrêté fort donc puis il
a voulu faire les chalets à tous alors
elle jamais vu le succès actuel en génie
succès ds 23 électronique et injection
non non non jamais mais je vais sur
leurs tombes et j'apporte est libre et
c'est la fnac saison
là les bouquins j'en parle avec eux ils
sont il a tout vu j'essaie de savoir
s'ils sont engueulés la veille tout ça
et je leur raconte et je leur racontais
jeu je n'ai jamais interrompu le
dialogue avec eux ce que je fais c'est
toujours relié ce que je veux c'est
qu'il soit faire demain pour le reste
brad et moi chez m'arranger avec moi
quoi mais je veux qu'ils soient fiers de
moi et qui trouvent que si l'on fait un
bon fils et bon fils c'est mon job
c'est à vue qu'à tf1 ils ont pris un
noir bref arrêt joker de poivre d'arvor
c'est bien oui et dans le dans 20
minutes que je dis chaque matin il y
avait un petit article pas persifleur
qui montrait la photo de ce mac donald
qui rentre à la bbc en 69 et qui est à
la retraite aujourd'hui le premier
présentateur
donc c'était un peu le voilà à mais les
français pensent toujours qu'ils sont le
pays d'aller je pense gens qui sont en
avance sur les autres à la soudure
journal temps en temps on s'aperçoit le
gars avec son joli sourire sa petite
moustache ses petites lunettes retraite
je suppose qu'il y ait deux poids été
anobli moteur de gens là quand on lui
parle du site januarie le arrêt anglais
déjà à la retraite mais la voilà
[Musique]
oui bonsoir bonsoir et il avait suivi et
vanessa dolmen mesdemoiselles au
quatrième étage merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
entre filles
tu n'as pas eu le temps de lire mon
livre alors non j'ai même temps jésus
j'ai lu des mines et des articles dessus
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas encore vu venir
mais j'attends la dédicace
il va sortir en poche toutes les
combinaisons du
seco should aura plus fait il n'ya
qu'une porte là donc je suis resté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdemoiselles bourgeois soir
comment allez-vous grand merci françois
fillon au manteau
or j'en ai pas beaucoup pas chanter le
printemps alors
voila
tu vas bien réduite
bonsoir
c'est la première fois que je vois comme
ça vous connaissez le chemin
ça mais c'est le printemps tu montres
est il très en forme
les filles les filles
black men in black pour deux belles
gonzesses on souhaite pour ma part faire
un truc à quatre américains d'accor
a tant attendu des émissions à l'ondé
nous qu'est ce que c'est tout débute on
a commencé le 27 février je croyais
mission 1 d un divertissement de sa
peine pour le plaisir sur le plaisir
c'est celui qui marche
pas
c'est quoi le pitch alors qu en
revisitant 40 ans de chanson française
de ce que je m'adapte télévision voilà
avec des images d'archivés on a invité
en plateau et puis le jeu fil rouge des
chemises big musical on chante on peut
chanter sur
scène qu'est ce qu'un petit peu un peu
difficile mais ont notamment touché les
petits
chl en asie gournay des bons je suis en
passe d'être autour de la chaîne i jy
enfin ce qu'est ce que tu as des misères
indépassable savez feront pas je me
contre 50 ha ouais ah oui oui là c'est
vrai on s'accroche on a de plus en plus
de monde et l'autre notre émission il
avait de nouvelles mélodies et l'ont
arrêté là les gens me d'eric voilà le
sauveur le sondeur départ
avec son giro même sur france 2 un
moment ils savaient plus quoi faire des
amis d'éric c'est le public avec mon
pote gay faire ouais mais je fais
toujours ubi qu'on sache vers la 200e
donc c'est affaire qui roule comment
parler de culture de manière sexy
on existants réalisé par appels au
secours mon plateau etc non mais c'est
une autre manière de faire de la culture
bien fait oui il est bien marié aussi
moi j'ai fait un livre avec la wii s'est
agacé le livre a cartonné et philippe
c'est vraiment un pro
c'est un jules noix ou blanc non non pas
toi non personne n'est parfait milliers
d'italiens déjà pas
franchement
moi le j'adore ce métissage de bons
potes moi j'ai j'avoue je sais pas si ça
vous fait quelque chose moi je j'ai tout
je suis toujours ému par un couple mixte
[Musique]
mais quel bordel me dit d'evry vont en
baver je le croise mais voilà mixtes ils
en ont bavé mais ils sont là voilà c'est
ben oui mon père est mon
cameroun et ma mère et du tarn blanche
normal qu pur produit couples mixtes
[Applaudissements]
oui bon choix soit
c'est ma gloire et cody quatrième
magloire
que c'était pas facile pour faut
imaginer se verrait en parler de sa
grand mère et grand-mère 1920 mais ça
remonte à magrie landaise tarbaise de la
bourgeoisie tarbaises qui épouse un de
résistance la part des gens de notre
propre métier mais c'est voir un noir
débarquer faire un prêt avec drucker
protégé par drucker et autres ça pose un
vrai problème tu sa jalousie profonde
mais du côté de tous les côtés de toutes
les communautés non uniquement de la
communauté française georges les
français noirs n'ont pas de problème au
contraire tu vois tu peux tu sais tu
sais ils sont plutôt pierre bemba est
maintenant là là dessus aucun problème à
marcher notre côté mais bon
c'est avec un bonhomme
annoncé violent mais sa journée à
sombrer dans l'alcool à cause de
certains tu as quand même c'est pas
évident notre problème à nous c'est les
dents ouais
on est toujours sur jalle nous mais
c'est vrai il a raison
moi je dis souvent est en fait attention
les dents c'est la façon la plus
gentille enfin le sourire c'est la façon
la plus gentille de montrer les
jeudi 6 à forger messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir oui le magma est habitué mais
robin élevé dit
bientôt mais aussi je réalise mes chers
merci pas des vêtements
qui n'est pas venu avec ton petit gino
j'ai évité j'hésitais
malicieux je pense que oui oui
c'est que le chien c'est une catastrophe
à ce mois-là à une catastrophe nos
martyrs et adopté le même petit
chihuahua qui arrivait avec un chihuahua
ici un soir j'appelle ma fille je dis
oui ninon c'est exactement le chien et
c'est vrai que c'est très beau c'est le
chien tu veux il en a acheté 1 puis
après béatrice à 10 quand même dommage
ce chien va s'ennuyer tout seul donc on
avait acheté un deuxième bon et on a ces
deux [__] de chernarus personnes ça
n'occupe team qui n'appauvrit c'est
toujours comme ça mais c'est toujours ça
la cataracte cyrielle c'est quoi déjà
très très très posé s'est agi par
toulouse où il a attaqué le plancher des
petites dents mais attaquer le plat le
plongea likoud serait il ya un trou dans
le plancher à cause d'un chef des grands
comme ça mais la mini beaucoup mieux et
c'est encore
ce couvert d'amour tu veux dire elle ne
me l'a jamais voir barrage aller
parfaitement voyage neuf jamais fait de
bêtise n'a jamais rien abîmer vos
parents ne vont certainement formidable
sa place vendôme ont tout cassé
à la tienne claudie faut dire celui-là
je te dirai grue car
[Applaudissements]
j'attends le verdict du grand frère
bombe alors il va coûter très bien mon
nom alors je te dire la vérité la
coiffeuse les sympathiques à gagner mais
je suis pas sûre de la chanson
c'est ce que certains disent suppression
de la chanson corneille est repassé en
studio ouais et il a retravaillé tout ça
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile de deux
ans même temps la france s'ils gagnent
leurs visions ils sont obligés
d'organiser
surtout qu'on était bien placé bien
classés ce serait ce serait ça m'a alors
tu sais en faisant cette émission avec
drucker j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi tu
n'as tu sais pourquoi parce que je me
suis souvenu lorsque tu as fait le
débarquement avec lui on a fait les
souffrances et les plus importants en
disant finalement c'est le taulier c'est
bien tout le monde appelle comme ça
maintenant
moi j'ai vu ce canal gelé depuis des
années il avait vraiment envie de faire
ça avec lui que j'étais comme un gamin
mais tu peux le respect que j'ai pour
lui la façon dont il m'a déroulé le
tapis rouge double épaisseur tu vois
j'étais vraiment aller sur l'énergie et
j'ai pensé à toi qui se respecte ua pour
lui c'est respect que j'ai pour lui et
ce qui est pas toujours le cas dans
notre dos notre métier de cesser le
taulier drucker vraiment vraiment un
vrai bonheur chez drucker moi je les ai
toujours vu à la télé c'est pas
compliqué depuis que mes parents ont
acheté la télé j'avais 15 ans il était
déjà là il toujours la fondue avec le
poste
je ma mère est une femme qui a passé sa
vie à se sacrifier que ce soit pour pour
des hommes en leur donnant le plus
d'amour en sacrifiant même son temps sa
dernière énergie est infirmière et pour
ses enfants en étant infirmière à
l'hôpital on leur ont dit non je ne veux
pas que la négresse me touche malgré
cela toutes ces belles soeurs sont sont
blanches et elle n'a jamais vu la
couleur de la peau des gens et ça pour
moi cette femme était une sainte et toi
t'es d'où alors bi zogbo ce que lui
c'est le plus je trouve lui alors et
c'est vraiment le moins noir de tous oui
parce que tu n'as aucune artois vraiment
tu vois aucune racine il faut que tu
connais mais en fait le truc c'est que
majid t je suis né en france du moment
togolaise qui avait 16 ans c'est à dire
la veille de son accouchement qu'elle
était enceinte merci les bonnes soeurs
du coin et
3 et 6 2 en haut
on appelait ça des pouponnières sonore
félina c'est là que j'ai commencé ma
carrière de séducteur autant de la
fedama à toutes les infirmières et c'est
là que ma mère celle qui m'a adopté
raphaël d'un 3-0 à y vendre ce cas de
cette petite gamine finalement tête
enfants et ce môme et moi j'ai eu un
souci de conformité toute mon enfance
c'est quand même est reparti au togo
qu'elle a eu l'autorisation de repartir
se marier parce qu'elles n'avaient qu'un
un prétendant qu'ils méritent à mon père
et on est partis au togo sur ces cinq
mois je dis je ne veux pas rester là je
refusais ce qui était africain j'ai moi
même si c'est à dire partir avec ma mère
blanche tu m'as adoptée par la suite et
tous quitté afrique tu crème savoir qu
cp on institutrice on devait étudier
l'afrique on n'a jamais étudié
d'africains ya quand même des les petits
lotois dans le but que quelques uns
une amicale du sud
et moi j'ai eu ce souci de conformité
qui faisait que je voulais j'ai tout
refusé jusqu'à une époque bénie d'
autour de 25 ans tu retourner au en
afrique et que aujourd'hui c'est plus
que nécessaire c'est aussi moi ouais
ouais la lave le foie gras labourer et
il m'a fait ouais donc l'essence du
phonographe ring
moi je ne sais pas si tu as vécu ça tu
as ta mère venue chercher à l'école ah
mais oui bien sûr 1 alors heureusement
village mais c'est tous les voyages à
l'extérieur c'est toujours oui c'était
toujours des questions des
interrogations même pas posée si le
regard de l'autre du monde et mes doigts
le sorcier vêtir l'a fait partir en
vacances en afrique ma pauvre dame
ma soeur aînée n'a pas même père que
nous elle est très très clairs de dreux
effectivement et à l'école tous les
enfants de l'isère en maternelle
jusqu'au bout c'est vrai à peu près mais
pourquoi elle et pas la même couleur que
toi ta soeur et ma soeur aînée répondait
à l'époque mais c'est parce que ma main
à laisser plus longtemps four mais tu
sais qu gentil il ya justement tout une
terminologie des ions lorsque tu as tu
es un peu clairs de peau on dit tu as
une petite couleur août à pau cela peut
sauver ou dit en créole ça veut dire
saucisse à des cessions et puis il ya
une expression que les antiennes
connaissent pas van noppen dans
d'inutiles ne connaissent pas la
signification c'est chabin ou chabine
desjardins met un terme animalier achats
ben c'est le croisement d'un bouc et
d'une chèvre tout comme par exemple le
terme de mulâtres sa salsa verde la
frappe de müller et les entier ne savent
pas ça alors longtemps chez nous même
les artistes je veux dire c'était
ambiance witty chabine lâche en tête y
avait des chansons très à la mode si
chaque bidon tisha mais moi je veux tout
sauf qu appelle ma copine site chabine
parce qu'elle est clair de peau
ridée merci aux antilles ces héritages
et les ouvrages plus la truck cabaret
autre n'était pas la même hiérarchie en
afrique je vous souhaite enfin de
métissage mais c'est vrai que par qui
s'y colle à la peau c'est encore autre
chose ça c'est à cause des mecs parce
que comme un messie si si si elle se
décolore la peau c'est parce que les
mecs préfèrent les femmes plus clair si
si
pour quelques
commerces et ça
laisse des couleurs voilà alors seul
toutes celles qui ont les moyens
achètent des produits mais c'est surtout
les mélanges avec l'ocha l'aide de la
souris puis si tu sais que ça désordre
après l'ex aussi
[Musique]
il
oui bon choix bonsoir gaston kelman bon
quatrième étage s'il vous plaît merci
michel bayet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame monsieur bonsoir à tous
choix au lac d'afrique splendide on aime
confie aux vêtements à gaston tv
nationaux ça va
mener
merci monsieur lampre
[Musique]
j'ai le maillet on sait pas ce qui a
fait sourire et gaston kelman
[Musique]
et c'est tout ce que
le lobby
société c'est un lobby
moi j'ai plein de moments de ma petite
histoire j'ai eu énormément d'éléments
de moments d'épisodes où je me senti
fier d'être d'être entier
lorsque michel maillet un jour de fin
d'année à la télévision française sur
antenne 2 à l'époque souhaite bonne
année à tous les hommes ça s'est tout
d'un coup j'ai vu ma mère ça arrache
du dirigeable que michel c'est terrible
je suis très mécontent d'être en face de
toi parce que tu aimes la première femme
qui me fait pleurer ton qui est parti et
je me rappelle même de ce qui est dit
lorsque tu as quitté l'antenne priés de
vous quitter je fais là j'essaie d'aller
en ce
moment c'est très xviiie ouais ouais
la première femme n'a cassé le petit jeu
n'était pas la première la première et
essaie d'être capricieuse loisirs est
capable
la première présentatrice de la
martinique c'était la toute première
avec cathy rosiers quartier rosemont à
retrouver aux côtés de jean pierre
melville et d'alain delon voilà jeune
âge allons la magnifique pianiste et je
trouve que le cinéma français a régressé
depuis parce que les rôles qui sont
proposés ne s'était c'était vraiment il
y à il ya les seniors il ya 35 heures va
beaucoup d'actrices y en a aucune s'il
veut faire des films avec ses bouquins
par exemple les chevaliers de saint-jean
il n'y a pas de manière dont ils
allaient la pâte comédiens banque a mené
sa vache mais ça aurait pas ce qu'il a
dit un prix très juste c'est qu'il ya
des histoires qui ne peuvent pas être
racontée c'est grave si appelé des
histoires racontées juste a pas des
acteurs pour les raconter c'est
extraordinaire d'être conscient c'est
pas simplement une affaire de perçage et
cyprès dire aux gens voilà toutes les
bonnes affaires de personne c'est des
histoires vont faire et son soutien à
les comédiens sont là le potentiel est
là mais mieux lorsque je suis arrivé en
france j'avais 25 ans lorsque c'est ça
fait pratiquement 25 ans avec le dit
lorsque je suis arrivé en france je suis
allé directement voir médias qui était
la plus grosse agence genre de comédie
et qui est toujours il y avait deux par
dieu il y avait deux verres il y avait
et on m'a dit je me suis entendu dire
que
qu'il n'y avait pas de rôles pour les
femmes de couleur et que les rôles qui
était présenté et que j'étais atypique
alors je leur ai demandé qu'est ce que
ça voulait dire être atypiques il m'a
été répondu que je n'avais pas le profil
de quelqu'un de couleur c'est à dire je
n'étais ni assez noir ni assez négroïde
et je n'avais pas les cheveux que vous
avez du sang couler un peu moi j'ai 4 4
4 à 4
5 ha
alors ce pétré grenouilleau parce qu'on
n'entend toujours pas il se paye très
gros niveau max gallo est venu m'en
parler qu'est ce qu'il a dit de 600
d'ici là rien d'extraordinaire il a dit
que le général péter
la météo
[Applaudissements]
ni des professeurs a annoncé un hôtel
qui américaine a montré que tout
simplement il y avait avant la traite
atlantique que l'on connaît il ya une
traite interne c'est à dire qu'il y
avait à l'intérieur de l'afrique que ce
soit du côté où des musulmans ou des
africains une traite interne inter
afrique bien sûr absolument
je vais os consommer
ça manque de diversité l'année nombre
j'adorais ça vous allez pouvoir de
gaulle et à djedda où il s'en va
s'impliquer un petit peu parce que ça
déjà mais moi ce qui m'a embêté c'est
que bon il parle des traites c'est à
dire qu'il a il a mis un pluriel qui est
un petit peu agacé résultat les
antillais l'ont attaquée non attaqué sur
le sujet et c'est là que j'ai trouvé que
c'était un petit peu et gasol a défendu
ben moi je trouve qu'il a absolument
raison de mettre en perspective les
traite plutôt que de ce sans tenir
simplement à ce commerce triangulaire
qui est un aspect de la traite
oui bonsoir bonsoir c'est un nid rouge
flybe et david pujadas au quatrième
étage complet
[Musique]
sinon on se retrouve avec cette idée un
petit peu étonnant c'est que le noir
serait complètement incapable de traite
moi c'est ça l'idée qu'il ya derrière
tout ça ça c'est faux c'est faux il ya
eu traite à l'intérieur tout très tôt
ces musulmans de faire notre homme
claudie bien sûr attend que je veux dire
dans l'esprit après on va on pourrait
détailler les cheveux mars et desquels
chauvel ouverte à une vie
banale aux roms qui nous sépare c'est
déjà beaucoup c'est un bon coup la
tablette négrière européenne elle n'a
rien à voir avec la traite
intercontinental elle n'a rien à voir
avec la traite arabe
avec le couloir parce que finalement la
tragédie esclavage elle n'est pas
simplement dans la déportation
elle est aussi durant plusieurs siècles
ce que l'on fait subir aux esclaves sur
les terres du 10 nouveaux mondes moment
[Musique]
bye bye messieurs bonjour bonsoir vingt
camions soit en soi
oui concevoir autrement
vous connaissez le chemin
nom n'apparaît clos décoder le prêt à
l'as dit maintenant un 10 mai prochain
mais j'ai vu d'image cgt là j'ai dit
mais vous mettez les prochains certain
bon sens veut dire on va passer on va
plus pour vincent collet à table non
mais je suis pas d'accord avec ça je
vois là faudra maintenant je veux
on va continuer à taper
absolument
alors attendez sur petronio moi j'en ai
entendu parler par max gallo qui acquit
voilà qui est qu'il là qu'il l'a défendu
les fantasques apparemment lui il dit a
pas eu qu'une seule traite il ya eu des
traites et toi tu dis c'est embêtant
parce que finalement la dirisi ça
relativise la traite oui parce qu'au
moment où on est dans un besoin réel la
france et pas simplement les français
noirs on a besoin de régler ce passé-là
et de justement de passer à autre chose
voilà des gens des historiens qui font
un travail remarquable certainement un
grand historien mais qui finalement veut
noyer cette traite qui n'est pas reconnu
cette nonne en attentant parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on va faire des gestes se
laisse parler
versatile et certains discours voilà ça
mais non ça va et ça nous empêche de
régler le problème le problème est
qu'aujourd'hui la france est dans une
danse dans une impasse où certains
français ont besoin que la france dise
c'est vrai voilà ce que nous avons fait
un an maintenant voilà ce que nous avons
fait et nous reconnaissons ça et c'est
ça qui est important et aujourd'hui où
nous avons juste envie que ce passé
commun cette histoire commune elles
soient digérées coli est ce que tu dis
quand même c'est aujourd'hui où la
france est en train d'essayer de régler
ce problème par contre c'est pas le
moment d'arriver avec quelque chose qui
complexifie le problème soit l'hôte et
j'ai juste
après je ne vais pas le dire à tout
suspense à dire si je vais le dire à ce
que je veux dire c'est que je suis
totalement d'accord avec l'otan qui
détient effectivement une espèce de
faire des centres qui dit nous on n'a
pas été si méchant que ça il ya quand
même eu les autres aussi c'est très
gênant par exemple aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que j'ai à [__] le mois qui a eu des
bons côtés d'un mauvais il ya des
mauvais côtés de la colonisation s'est
elle aussi barbare qu'il est est
blâmable aujourd'hui pourquoi il
vraiment qu'une école va racheter des
bides d'êtres humains jeudi que le fait
de vouloir pouvait le nom à parti c'est
méchant mais je dis à mes amis blancs et
à mettre les blancs patate et j'ai pas
besoin de ça pour être français vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous justifier cela
s'est passé il ya sans faille à 50 ans
c'est comme ça que j'ai dit et c'est
vrai que là je suis je te rejoins dix
ans par contre le travail d'historien ne
rentre pas là dedans
il s agit surtout d aussi bien qu'on
instrumentalise et l'accent sera aussi
utilisé alors voilà c'est vous paraît
non non taillés un truc qui va attend
des questions le gars pourquoi ya pas un
historien de black qui est traiter ce
problème là abbas et le jeune oliver
j'en fais les bienvenus soulevé par
exemple mais ça c'est pas d'annoncé
corbel place n'est pas l'arabe non
claudine a tenté plus yarki ramon depuis
la conquête des couches se passer demain
20 ans par l'antériorité de ça il essaie
d'avoir des étudiants il a des problèmes
avec la cité par le point des taux de 8
à l'université française lui qui veut
pas quelle drôle de signes
[Applaudissements]
tu sais ce que tu disais à parole de la
marine comme dans dans pagnol monsieur
la marine française
à la santé mary haricots nord aride qui
nous veut du bien bon alors ça s'est
passé comment l'histoire la basse
cameron s'est offert kit vous avez
ensuite parce que je sais c'est que
chaque année vous recevez des gens très
importants dans des dîners dans des
matchs un et que martin bouygues après
un dîner c'est ce que je sais c'est être
de la vulgate mais que martin bouygues
après un dîner au club averroès a pris
conscience et il a fait cette chose
extraordinaire faut bien le dire de
mettre ce harry comme joker de poivre
d'arvor c'est énorme non non non enfin
j'ai assez poussées poivre d'arvor car
marqué le premier harry oui et au cours
d'un dîner c'est vrai et ensuite il ya
eu un second dîner avec mougeotte et
namias et là ils ont effectivement
percuté ils ont souhaité leur côté
doivent d'abord le premier c'est lui qui
a carte qui a repéré enfin le le dal ont
le talent ont
annoncé vu qu'on a parlé à mme
yami jonas qui a posé dans la une de
télérama avec le visage tout noir
il faut car il posément
quand on reprend le discours de
mougeotte a été plus parce que l'alu
talent parce qu'il est noir et et et
c'est le plus important pour moi parce
qu'il faut de la diversité culturelle à
l'athénée l'avez peut-être pas fait
attention à cela la diversité culturelle
née à 1 poitiers c'est vrai que ça parce
que tu rêves a dit
oui allez culturel parce que dans sa
sensibilité
il va peut-être tenir ou parler de
sujets différemment elle a dit que
commencera le serbe du jury
koné
s'est unie ça oui ça veut dire qu'on
ferait ses sujets en fonction de ce que
l'on est c'est ça qui m'intéresse moi
bien au lieu de passer quand on
regardait donc nous sommes tous élevés à
l'idée que la télévision traite les
sujets de façon objectif mais ça c'est
intéressant parce que ce type de ce type
d'événement il va mettre en évidence que
on était dans le subjectif alors qu'on
croyait à la télévision rai dans
l'objectif
hero 2 voilà et les dîners régulièrement
et légendes averroès centraide et et
c'est effectivement de promouvoir les
minorités visibles à l'antenne c'est
très bien si on était aux états unis on
dirait c'est un lobby dans toute
l'acception du terme ils se seraient
l'oeuvre du tout souci en france quand
on y lobby ça paraît tout de suite un
peu loose nous convient pas mais sinon
c'est ça et moi je
aucune fonction dans l'aveyron est
simplement je suis un vieil ami d'ami
rouge et je suis vivant sciences au
terrorisme on va faire un livre ensemble
à un moment donné où on n'en parlait pas
beaucoup sur la montée de l'islamisme
dans les banlieues juste avant les à 113
95 on a été rattrapé par l'actualité et
le bouquin plutôt bien vieilli si on
veut relier ce jour vers la cité dans
toutes les études
en fait ont aidé d'un déni et le déni
c'est cette diversité et on n'a pas
compris pourquoi c'est effectivement
cette diversité n'évoluez pas de manière
naturelle ce soit dans les milieux
politiques milieux économiques et les
médias et donc enfin on a eu cette
réflexion et david et david m'a dit mais
vas-y font de ce club va voir monsieur
parce que le point important c'est qu'à
merrouche me disant rocher et c'est est
frappé au coin du bon sens il me dit
s'il n'y a pas de noirs et d'arabes qui
veulent faire les écoles de journalisme
c'est parce qu'il ne vous ne se voit pas
à l'ancienne et qui se disent c'est pas
un métier pour moi et c'est la poule et
l'oeuf et la poule et l'oeuf et si j'ai
quelque part on enclenche pas la
dynamique perçu ça ne se fera jamais
d'abord
on y va alors pardon livre cder simone
veil le dit dans sa préface c'est vrai
que c'est un livre c'est l'histoire
d'une dune noir qui est déporté à
auschwitz un avent brute
s'est évidemment des choses qu'on sait
peu en fait que le collège ont été
déportés
déportés comme les tziganes comme les
comme l'esl avec star mais ce que je
trouve c'est que tu ne rentres pas et
c'est ce que dit simone veil dans sa
préface tu rentres pas dans la banque a
complété mais moi dans là et ça c'est
sûr midam dire que tu parles de la shoah
est évidemment et en même temps ce
destin se greffe à l'intérieur de ça et
n'est pas en concurrence avec ça et ça
je trouve c'est ce qui est le plus beau
dans son livre c'est vraiment
une histoire de cette fille qui est qui
et déportés dont qui prend qui ont
embarqué dans les wagons plombés tout ça
pour shalit elle redécouvre l'esclave
âge et ses expériences parce qu'elle se
rend compte qu'elle se dise que je vis
c'est ce qu'ont vécu finalement
c'est une manière d'aller de l'esclavagé
alors qu'elle est sous la colonie
aujourd'hui ce que tu as écrit à 10 ans
à plus de force oui je me dis pour se
dire en termes de l'échangé savais pas
voilà voilà voilà et dont elle ignorait
ce livre a moins eu d'impact il ya dix
ans qu'il en a aujourd'hui la moyenne
impact aussi parce que bon j'étais aux
éditions françois bourin
plus de chance je proteste un manuscrit
depuis dix ans on n'a pas voulu on en a
voulu il ya deux ans voilà 6 6 à 7 10 le
sel gaston qu'une succession contact
tu es j'étais prof est un jour dans une
manifestation devant le rectorat en mai
tous les ans de façon sempiternel
chercher il ya des jeunes beurette qui
sont nova fait monsieur vous êtes prof
ouais vous êtes vous êtes beurre
non moi je suis juste d'origine
martiniquaise aux minces pour une fois
qu'on avait l'impression d'avoir un
professeur d'origine et ce sera vous ce
sera vous donc nous sommes d'accord avec
son nom n'avait pas d'accord on n'est
jamais seul ce que l'on incarne de
médias que l'on savait au moment où
voilà on est prêts sincèrement
ça tombe pas bien merci mes chers vas-y
que je te parle aussi de l'importance de
la vie vous annoncer le sagouin
l'exemple nom de l'exemplarité de
l'exemplarité dis moi tu le dit tu en es
où avec dieudonné là où j'en suis et
dieudonné oui parce que tu es mais c'est
incroyable histoire là c'est à dire que
voilà un mec finalement en 2004 en
février au moment où ce gars ne peut pas
faire son spectacle à l'olympia où je
trouve aussi que son sketch il a le
droit d'énoncer à la limite une
politique étrangère parce que c'est un
com et que militant je trouve que le à
israël étaient trop était vraiment trop
même si on peut retrouver aussi que le
sketch était pas bon mais qu'importe et
mais qui est dans une posture idée il
dénonce un truc auquel a droit ça a
choqué des gens qui s'excuse il le fait
laissez le travailler comme que la cité
française ne partent pas dans ce genre
de dérives et de trucs et moi je
trouvais que lui en tant que qu'artiste
devait continuer à travailler maintenant
il y a eu par la suite landais le 20
février 2004 et a eu par la suite des
choses qui moi m'ont semblé être de
nature à créer un schisme dans la
société française et c'est ça qui est le
plus grave est donc à ce moment là
lorsqu'il y a le l'histoire de la
pornographie mémorielle à alger il me
dis donc et je me permets de dire j'aime
pas répéter les conversations comme s'en
priver il me dit mais je n'ai fait que
reprendre les propos de jeu lui et je
lui n'en attends attends je lui dis
compte tenu de tout ce qui s'est passé
tu n'as pas légitimité à parler et a
forcément jeté l'opprobe sur une
communauté sur une partie de la france
julie c'est clair et à ce moment là donc
moi je suis pas d'accord qu'il y ait
continué cons et qu'on a et qu'on
remonte et que intel 10 intelligentes
elles disent je veux pas dire que de
l'autre côté il ya des gentils et que
lui c'est le méchant ouais je suis en
train de dire qu'à un moment donné je ne
suis plus d'accord parce que je ne me
reconnais plus moi qui suis un gamin qui
était élevé je suis d'une génération
fabuleuse où j'ai été élevé avec des
juifs avec des maghrébins avec des
africains des antillais des blancs
d'oeufs de france est finalement les
parents se connaissaient les allécher
les autres moi je connais la culture
juive ou la culture musulmane comme je
connais ma propre culture donc et je ne
comprends pas que je me retrouve dans un
truc où finalement ça casse tout ce dont
toutes ces valeurs que ma mère m'a donné
et tout ce que j'ai appris mais surtout
fait je vais déjà
des débats comme et de l'autre non
m'attendre mais c'est ce que je suis en
train j'essaye de dire les choses de
façon un peu et il se trompe c'est
certainement mais aussi en face de lui
il a des gens qui sont tout aussi
extrémistes et envies de 2,2 de créer
des décisions maintenant et donc on est
en face de gens ont envie de tous les
prendre leur dire je vous fous tous à la
poubelle les mecs parce que la france
est pas ça c'est pas en tout cas la
france que moi je connais que nous
connaissons je crois en tout cas et
c'est pas la france que l'on vit de nos
enfants donc stop on arrête
tu sais toi excuse moi tu sais quoi je
pense que l'église catholique quarante
et un grand coup après la mort de jean
paul ii
il faiblit littérateurs à venir
je suis catholique
le pape noir c'était la preuve d'abord
que le de l'universalisme du c'est vrai
christianisme
pour nous chrétiens 5e catholique
c'était quelque chose qui ont décapité
six ans bourré ils ont pris un agent
c'est pas pareil il fallait on avait
besoin de ja paul ii à l'est jean-paul
jak2 on avait besoin de personne
le communisme est un acte politique
était tout à fait je veux dire qu'il
était au bord du gouffre à bien une
chiquenaude y tombe en afrique n'est pas
encore aujourd'hui dans ce niveau de
développement où un pape qui émergera de
ce peuple avancé quelque chose on aura
que des regrets à dire même le pape n'a
rien pu faire en afrique parce que kofi
annan aujourd'hui quand même qui est le
secrétaire général de l'onu devant n'a
pas apporté aux peuples africains pas
parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas parce qu'il ne
pouvait pas réapparaître
alors que on a on a assisté à la
dégringolade du communisme ne masquera
pas vu faire une chiquenaude imaginons
sincèrement s'oriente sur ie une
fraction de seconde on laisse de plus de
même pour le parloir l'enseignant les
yeux c'est notamment dans les yeux un
pape noir nous reviendra forcément
mais ça veut dire qu'ils le méritent
qu'on est
positive la salle sans cesse la
transformation positive de suite
ces quatre monnaies l'esprit de
contradiction non bah c'est bien
j'ai bien servi j'étais peut-être
était-elle thème concours j'étais au
congo parce que je veux pouvoir rire de
ça vous avez vu dans mon premier livre
j'aime me et le florilège des blagues
savez ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que tout ses blagues à quelques trois
quatre exceptions près sont des blacks
blancs des belges sauf qu on peut le
faire aux blondes entre le verrou belge
n'a pas le droit de le faire au noir
tout le monde m'a tiré dessus même ceux
qui ont adoré le livre de médiation les
black album live c'était un peu trop
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne peut pas rire
par exemple aujourd'hui fait que
qu'est-ce qui est plus bête que noir du
noir franchement je dis une banalité
d'une nullité absolue canal hier c'était
à l'époque à circuler de l'histoire
franchement aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une histoire que le noir
n'était pas énorme au début du siècle je
crois que la première valorisation du
noir dallas de platine la
présidentialisation du noir s'était
adapté bien valorisation de noah serait
le tireur se régaler enfin c'était un
signe de reconnaissance
de la brabus de ce même de sa beauté de
sa présence de son courage de son
courage à la courage c'est à dire à
lionel des grenades des voyous on a
dévoyé le liban la raison on a dévoyé
l'image aucune alerte quand le tireur le
tirailleur sénégalais est ce que c'est
une figure de l'histoire de france est
ce que le tirailleur sénégalais est
quelque chose de complètement en gluten
mais c'est pas la seule et pour
l'instant j'ai la solution
daniel est en gazon ce qui veut dire
c'est qu'ils préfèrent voir le
tirailleur sénégalais dans le film qui
s'appelle indigènes plus sur la
publicité de [__] mais père disparaît
de [__] sait faire disparaître la
critique de [__] c'est à dire faire
disparaître l'idée existe quelque chose
sur lequel on peut réagir tu le fais
disparaître mais j'essaie tout le
problème de l'histoire avec fabrice
torricella jeudi 10 mars et la rue voilà
déjà disparu on en parle peu ordinaire
donc on ne réagit pas à s'installer
c'est assez grave david ça c'est grâce à
12 heures à l'espace de généralisation
des noirs qui m'agace méritants de
savoir que c'est les antillais qui se
bat contre le [__] ça aussi ça
m'agace pourquoi n'irait pas parce qu'il
ya trop de noirs
il ya des actes il ya des africains il
ya des américains il ya des tabous lui
même qui se consomme à soleure non matin
j'ai terminé blanche des frères étaient
pourtant on nous a prouvé que nous
étions tous pareils au noir et c'est que
le fondement la création du noir est une
création de blanc on
me demandait l'autre le jour mais qu'est
ce que tu penses de la rue jeudi elle
n'existe pas en bon je m'attendais
définissez la moitié africain oui oui tu
le dis aujourd'hui mais généralement
tendance à passer la crise à des deux
côtés du
salat ans c'est bien un truc énorme tu
as dit lenoir est une création du blanc
parce qu'en fait il ya des gens qui
viennent se plaint de pays différents je
ne savais rien le dire est ce qu'elle
est noire est ce qu'elle est noire mais
le président chirac était à madagascar
commencer
le président malgache le président
malgache l'a dit monsieur le président
je suis en quarts à 9 vos affaires de 47
j'étais pas là ce qui est mal ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui le regard que
vous posez sur moi j'ai gagné les
élections il ya deux ans trois ans vous
avez soutenu sûr qu'on aghlal jusqu'à la
limite de l'acceptable le peuple malien
le flop le malien m'a élu mais vous avez
continué à soutenir look vous pouvez
toujours pleurer sur 47 moi je peux que
vous pleuriez sur maintenir
quelles que soient les devoirs de
mémoire qui nous occupe je pense qu'il a
raison c'est vrai qu'il vaut mieux
s'occuper de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
que démarrent leur laisse que des
massacres ont eu lieu la rentrée si sûr
en 45 à malaga
voilà un continent qui est dépensé
totalement terminée pour lui c'est fini
le congo belge avec mon goût mais
j'étais même la chasse gardée du roi
léopold quand même un qui finalement il
fait c'est tellement énorme qu'il en
fait don après l étape et
quatrième
on le ferait très mal
combien ça
m
[Musique]
un jour
madame monsieur bon choix
[Applaudissements]
benoît
enfin l'iphone
scène ce
bébé à dieu
[Musique]
le match prit
fin des
folles you can't be quiet
[Musique]
ça
ob année
là
ou
pas
jada c'est moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu